And now it's the old scout master.
It was really fortunate I got down to camp again this week. just to you know, look around, talk to some of the counselors, talk to the
Orienteering Counselor, who I really like. He has a very magnetic personality,
Even though he can be a little overbearing at times. I declined to needle him about all that.
Hey, this is podcast number 74..
Hey, welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green.
So, uh, yeah, sorry about that there at the beginning. puns, more puns.
You didn't know there were that many scouting puns, did you?
No, my goodness,
Ron Morris, scout master of troop 494 in Olathe, Kansas, wrote in and said: love the podcast.
He said with regards to how many listeners you have,
you should probably consider those who copy and share the MP3 files with other leaders.
Oh, I know people do that every once in a while, Ron.
Ron says he's giving copies to his assistant scout masters.
Well, thanks, Ron, Appreciate it.
He did have a problem being able to download a couple of the podcasts when we went in and fixed that.
Uh, thanks for being my eyes and ears and my quality control people, Ron and everyone else.
If you find a problem, yeah, do get in touch, Let me know.
You get in touch by emailing me at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet
Or you can go to scoutmastercgcom.
We got a contact form and all kinds of fancy schmancy stuff over there.
So the newsletter went out this week, the June edition of the newsletter,
and the theme in this newsletter is the patrol method
And the giveaway in this newsletter is several copies of working the patrol method,
which is a really transformative book and it comes with a very high recommendations
And it will really aid you if you're a scoutmaster, assistant scoutmaster
or you work with a Boy Scout group. Great book to have.
So get over to scoutmastercgcom and make sure you're subscribed to the newsletter
so you can get future newsletters, future giveaways.
So really interesting thing happened this week.
I had a package in the mail and that package came from a scouter in Pittsfield Mass, Bill McFarland,
And Bill has this really interesting thing going on.
If you're old school scouting and you go back probably a little farther than you'd like to admit,
you'll remember in Boy's Life magazine there was a column called Whittling Gym
And Whittling Gym had a necrochip slide in it every month
And if you got your pen, knife and a piece of wood and the column
you could carve yourself a necrochip slide.
He always had some kind of cool, interesting idea.
Well, Bill got the idea that he would go through
and he would carve all of the Whittling Gym necrochip slides
And he's keeping track of that on a blog called Channeling Whittlin Gym
and it's channelingwhittlingymblogspotcom,
and there'll be a link to Bill's blog in the post that contains this podcast.
Now. so I opened up the package and what is it?
Well, it's a necrochip slide that Bill has carved.
that is kind of the logo that I've been using for the past five or six years
on the podcast and on the blog of the saluting scout master.
And boy, what a nice gift.
There's a post about making it over at channelingwhittlingymblogspotcom
and some very kind words from Bill and I just wanted to recognize that
and I was very touched. very nice gift and I really do appreciate it, Bill.
In other things going on, let's see here
I got a book called Primitive Paradise by David Disselhorst
and I've just started reading it, got a good skim through it and everything like that
and what it's about is it's about scout camping in the United States
and it's actually a pretty interesting piece of work.
It centers mostly on one scout camp.
The author, David Disselhorst uses the experiences of this one scout camp
to kind of ponder the bigger issues about scout camping
and the way it's handled and what its future is.
I think it's a worthy book.
Hopefully we'll get to talk to David here on the podcast at one point,
but I wanted to let you know about the book,
and there's a link to it in the post that contains this podcast.
So this time around, scout master ship in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk a little bit about summer camp
and we do have a comment that came through on the blog
to talk about in our listener answer section that we have here,
and that's enough for any good podcast, don't you think?
Hey, I do, So let's get started.
Scout master ship in seven minutes or less.
One of the most fun things I've gotten to do in scouting
was be on our camp staff,
and I was able to do that for about 12 years
as a director in different departments and as a camp director,
and so the advice I'm about to give you
is kind of based on watching hundreds of different troops
and thousands of different scout leaders over those 12 years
come and experience a week of summer camp.
There's some common difficulties and problems that arise
and there's some things that you can do
that will just make things go a lot better for you
while you're there at camp with your scouts.
Now, scout camp is a great place to go if you're a scout.
It's fun, there's lots of challenges, there's great stuff to do
and it's the same as when you're an adult.
It's just a little bit of a different level.
Now, if it's the first couple of times you go to scout camp,
it can be very stressful. you can be faced with a lot of new things,
a lot of things that you're unfamiliar with.
you're not quite sure what the expectations are.
so you do have to take real good care of yourself.
Now that's if you've been going to camp,
if this year is your first time or your 25th year going,
you have to take good care of yourself physically,
because if you take good care of yourself physically
you're going to be in good shape mentally to handle camp.
Our camp is one of the only remaining ones
that has a seven day schedule.
We bring everybody in on Sunday
and they leave on the following Sunday,
So somebody gets to camp. you know
your average adult leader gets to camp on a Sunday afternoon
and the first day of camp. that's kind of stressful.
there's a lot of things to do, there's new things to learn,
there's people to meet, places to get to,
and you might feel a little bit rushed.
and by the time you're headed off to bed that night
you're probably pretty tired
and you may sleep well and you may not.
and you know the food's going to be a little different,
the water's going to be a little different,
your latrine's going to be a latrine.
you're going to have a lot of the same experiences
that the boys do with unfamiliar stressors
and things like that.
but you're also going to be older than they are.
I don't know if you notice that.
so you know your abilities are going to be
compromised, maybe by being a bit older than they are,
being a little more set in your ways,
and you could become cranky real fast.
and how do I know this?
Do I have to tell you?
I mean, I've been there,
I've done it,
I've not taken very good care of myself physically,
and then I get real cranky
and yeah, then things just get ugly.
so if you are hot, tired, hungry, thirsty,
you need to get cool, you need to get rested,
you need to get fed and you need to get hydrated,
and that's going to be a pretty big service to you
yourself personally,
your fellow leaders, your troop and the camp staff.
if you're not cranky and mean,
it's going to make the whole week go a lot easier.
so that's one key piece of advice.
you're coming into a situation
that you may not be familiar with,
but you've got a staff there,
people who are adults
and who've been at it for a long time-
and then you've got young adults,
guys who are around college age,
who got a lot of energy
and may have been at the camp staff job for several years.
and then you've got a bunch of younger staff members
who are basically learning right along with your scouts.
they're learning a lot of things right along with your scouts.
now they probably are a little bit farther ahead of them
as far as the camp things go,
but maturity-wise and things like that,
they're going to be more like your average 15,, 16, 17-year-old
and you've got to take that into account.
you need to be considerate and supportive of them
in the same way that you're considerate
and supportive of your scouts.
you never, ever want to step in
and be raid or criticize or argue
with a camp staff member.
you don't want to do that with a youth leader in your troop,
you don't want to do that with a fellow adult leader
and you certainly don't want to do that
with the presence of scouts.
and now, how much you may think
that that staff member deserves it,
what you want to do is you want to have
either a quiet talk with them
or their boss
at an appropriate distance from the scouts,
and that will usually solve the problem,
and sometimes that might be your problem.
you have to realize that camp staff members
are totally dedicated to making your stay worthwhile
and your idea of what might be right
and their idea of what might be right
could be two different things.
so you kind of got to go with the flow a little bit.
you got to join in the program
and encourage your scouts to do so,
even if the program, in your humble opinion,
isn't all that great.
if you go to a scout camp
and you're eating a dining hall,
there's usually a program around the dining hall time
and you know it may be
a really great whiz, bang,
high energy program.
it might not be all that great.
it encourages a lackluster
kind of difficult program as a lively audience.
a lively audience goes a long, long way
and you and your troop,
with the right attitude, could be the catalyst
that makes for a great week for everybody in camp.
you know, in the vast scheme of things,
I know that
as a staff member and as a director at camp,
we always emphasize that we were serving scouts
and scout leaders
and we were doing our dangest
to make them comfortable
and to make things work well for them.
now that's being said,
you don't want to go pulling rank
as a adult or a scout leader.
you don't want to ask for special privileges.
you don't want to try and impress the staff
members with your self importance.
a lot of people
instantly respect your position
as a scout leader
and they're going to
try and do their best for you.
just don't make a big giant deal out of it.
there's really no rank to be pulled there
and remember that these guys are working hard,
trying to help you.
so just go easy.
you need to look for the
opportunities to participate
with a lot of gusto
and a lot of spirit in ceremonies
and traditions and practices at camp,
even if they're unfamiliar to you.
if it's the first time you end up at a scout camp,
you know, maybe it's a new one
that you're trying out with your troop,
get into it,
jump right in.
camps and camp staff members
are very proud of their traditions
and you don't want to try to impose the way that
everybody did it at the last camp you were at
or the way that you think it should be done.
let them call the shots,
let them run the show
and just jump in and have a great time with it.
you'll be a camp with a lot of different scout troops
who will be run one way-
and you know you might be doing things
in a different way
and sometimes little inner troop rivalries
may develop.
now, scout age boys, as you know,
they're pretty hyper competitive
and they need to be reminded
about fairness and courtesy and sportsmanship
every once in a while.
so you want to set the tone,
when there's competition,
of it being a gentlemanly scout like competition,
and you want to make sure that you require that of your scouts.
as always
with anything we do in scouting,
give our youth leaders all the responsibility
for success,
see that they understand what needs to be done,
how and why, and then observe them
from a respectful distance,
check in with them every evening,
ask lots of questions
and put your ore in when you're asked for it
where it's a matter of safety.
but otherwise, let them run their troop.
let them work with the camp program
and the camp staff to do that.
you can run a lot of interference by learning
what happens next for them
or if you have the experience
that you can share with them,
but let them have all the responsibility
and all the credit
for the success of their troop.
you know, be proud of your scouts,
encourage them and congratulate them,
admire them. don't try to be one of them
because you know
you're too old for that now.
there'll be some opportunities
when you can join in the fun
at more or less the boy level.
jump in and have fun,
but don't interfere.
so those are a few things that are going to help you
when you get to Scout Camp this year.
next time around we're going to talk a little bit more.
we're going to talk about preparing parents for Scout Camp.
we're going to talk about homesickness
and things like that,
but we'll be doing that in future. podcasts,
e-mail,
e-mail, that is. folks,
and here's an answer to one of your e-mails.
there's a post on the blog this week.
it got a lot of discussion.
parents should force,
encourage, cajole their boys
to stay in Scouts
and we just talked about some of the broad underlying concepts
of what happens when boys are
the age that they are,
you know, in that middle school,
in those high school years,
when things change,
what signs we should be looking for and everything like that.
one of the replies I thought was kind of interesting
to that discussion
was from Ann Hendricks in Griffin, Georgia,
who has a boy who's a tenderfoot Scout
and it says we encourage him,
we don't push him,
but we've decided
that he's not going to be allowed
to get a driver's license
or a date until he becomes an Eagle Scout.
what do you think?
well, Ann, I don't know.
it's kind of hard to say because
I don't want to give advice to parents
about how to raise their children.
I can give you advice about
how to deal with Scouts and things like that.
I've been around long enough
that I've seen people try this plan
and I've seen it work
and I've seen it not work so great.
you're talking about a tenderfoot Scout,
so he's going to be 11, 12, maybe 13
at the oldest,
I would imagine,
and that 11 or 12 or 13 year old
is going to be a different person
when he's 14, 15 or 16.
it's just part of growing up.
they change quite a bit.
their ideas change,
what they like changes
and I don't think
I don't know if it's a legitimate thing
for parents to start out
with an 11 year old and say,
well, it's going to be thus and so
when you're 16, and expect
there not to be any mitigating circumstances
between now and then.
then again, like I said, I've seen that plan work.
I've seen people
who've created that rule
and held that up
and managed to work it
and work it well.
it has a lot to do with the personality of the boy.
it has a lot to do with the personality
of the parents and the circumstances
they find themselves in.
I will advise this:
when you're raising an adolescent boy,
flexibility
is a pretty important skill to have.
it's a pretty important thing.
you've got to be rigidly flexible.
there are some things that you can give in on
and some things that you can
work with.
there are going to be some standards that you're going to have to uphold,
but
so far as scouting goes,
I would make sure that if that is
the way that you're going to manage it,
that the scout master knows
you keep up with it
and you help him.
you help him make that goal,
and you do that not by doing the work for him,
but by being encouraging,
by being supportive
and helping remind him that he has this goal
in front of him, because
we all have set this up in such a way
that he owns the goal,
that it's not something that you're imposing on him,
but it's something that he owns
and that he agrees is a good idea.
so I know there's probably a lot of
people listening who have some thoughts
on this particular question.
I'd love to have you get in touch with me
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
thanks for listening
and here's how to keep in touch.
you read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's scoutmaster
letter C,
letter G dot com.
when you go to scoutmastercgcom
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster newsletter.
that's a monthly.
that's a monthly digest of the scoutmaster blog and podcast.
that's a monthly digest of the scoutmaster blog and podcast
around
usually like a central theme
with some good scouting resources,
and every newsletter includes a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors.
this month's newsletter,
it's several copies of
Working the Patrol Method
and you can find my review
and an interview with the authors of
Working the Patrol Method right there on the blog.
you can subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes
and when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or review or rating.
you can also call and leave a voicemail comment or question
at 484-734-0002.
that's
484-734-0002,
that's 484-734-0002,
that's 484-734-0002.
and finally, Clark Green
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet,
at Verizonnet.
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they dorsal or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me
and I've got a microphone and I'm trying to lend a hand to
out leaders and perhaps have a little bit of fun with it.
Well, before we leave you, let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
My thank you, sir,
Until next time.